well turkey isn't the only thing on
people's minds this Thanksgiving morning
many Americans will be searching for the
best holiday deals as we approach Black
Friday this holiday season online sales
are expected to increase a new record of
more than get this 143 billion dollars
reporting with Abby according to Adobe
which tracks internet retailers that's a
more than 14 percent increase from 2018
so how do you know if you're getting the
best deals Sharon Profis executive
editor and director of the content from
our partners at CNET joins us now so I
think what people want to know is where
and how do you get the best deals on
Black Friday
so the best deals are actually happening
right now I always think you don't
actually have to shop on Black Friday
you can do your shopping this morning on
Thanksgiving and then get back to
cooking your turkey the real deal though
is to get someone in the stores to tell
you what's happening on Black Friday or
Thanksgiving right I mean that insiders
knowledge yes so where is the best place
to do the shopping in the store or
online this year especially online is
becoming the place to do the best
shopping so it use for convenience or
because it's actually cheaper a little
bit of both right so it used to be that
you had to go into the store to get the
best deals but we're seeing a lot of
retailers replicate the same deals
in-store and online and the best part
about shopping online at home is that
you can do that comparison shopping you
go into the store you're stuck in that
store you don't have a lot of options
and if you came for a doorbuster deal
there's a good chance that they have a
very you know small amount of inventory
and then you're stuck with whatever they
have loved big-ticket item air pods and
Apple watches what's the best deal where
can we find them yeah so we're seeing
steep discounts on Apple products which
by the way never happened ever never so
we're seeing great deals on the Apple
watch especially you can get it for as
little as much as $200 off right now
which is a great gift earpods we've seen
as low as 129 not for the pro but for
the series or the second model so today
is a great day to buy Apple products why
are they discounted there well they're
discounted because
other retailers are actually discounting
them so in this case we're talking about
Walmart's discounts in particular oh wow
we knows that 50% of holiday shopping
growth will be because a smartphone
shopping what does that say about where
we're going in terms of not just using
the computer but doing everything on our
phones yeah consumers are becoming way
more comfortable with shopping on their
phones I think a big part of it is that
it's actually becoming more of a
streamlined seamless experience and what
we're seeing is retailers are responding
to this new behavior by offering ways to
bridge the gap between shopping on your
phone and going into the store so an
increase in buy online pick up in store
is happening target has a new drive up
option so you buy it on your phone
drive your car into a specific parking
the stall and they'll actually bring the
product out to you so it's kind of the
best of both worlds a lot of scams out
there so reliability is key how do you
make sure you're getting the real deal
yeah the one of my favorite tools is
camel camel camel that's a funny name
but you really can't forget it you want
to make sure that the discount you're
seeing is a special and a rare discount
so you go to camel camel camel enter in
the URL of the product you're shopping
for and it'll let you know what the
prices story was maybe it's actually
dropped down to that fries a few times
this year the other thing to look out
for is fake reviews so we've seen an
increase in fake reviews this year in
the FTC jumping on it so but here's my
question how do I know that a review is
fake cuz it says verified you got the
five stars people comment how do you
know that it's fake yeah it's um I
always recommend being very skeptical of
all reviews and use a tool called fake
spot.com
to find out how reliable those reviews
are again you just enter the URL of the
product you're looking for and they have
an algorithm that helps us out how
accurate those reviews are how reliable
they are spots com when did you start
shopping I started shopping on Monday
Black Friday is really Black Friday
weekly you can start shopping very early
and not worry about stressing on things
giving I started last Black Friday
everything's good sharing profits thank
you very much